كله تجربه سياسيه تستوجب
تخطيطا والتفكيرا وتستوجب كوادر وتستوجب
قدرات وهذه لم يكن يملكها
التيارات التي صعدت بعد الثوره لانها
تكونت على عجل ولان شبابها لم يكونوا
قادرين على ان يستوعبوا الواقع ويدركم
الواقع ويفهموا ما المطلوب منهم وان
الكثيرين قد فتحوا خصومات عقائديها
وخصومات ايديولوجيا ايوه بقى ان ينكبوا
معالجه الواقع والسعيدي تغييره علما بان
اداره الشان العام ليست قضيه سهله هي قضيه
تستوجب معرفه تستوجب قدرات تستوجب تخطيطا
وهذا مما يتوفر لحركه النهضه في تونس كما
لم يتوفر لكثير من الحركات السياسيه
الاخرى ولذلك في تصوري الفشل كان فشل
دريعا للجميع بالتفاوت المسؤوليه فيه
يقيننا
[موسيقى]
انها مبعده عن الحكم بعيد عن الحكم كغيرها
من
الحركات التي همم
اراد الشعب ان يبدها اذا كان هناك قرار
لابعاد حركه من الحركات فلا يغير في ذلك
انتم تعلمون بان الاحزاب في العالم الغربي
تتداولوا على الحكم يسقط الجمهوريون ويصعد
الديمقراطيون يبقون ثمانيه سنوات ينزلون
يسقط الثاني العمال والمحافظون هذا طبيعي
جدا
ولا اتصور ان الحركات الاسلاميه تريد ان
تبقى في الحكم ابدا الدهر لان الدوام ليس
من شيمه الحركات السياسيه حركات سياسيه
تعالج واقعه المتغيره ينبغي ان تنسحب عن
الحكم اذا لم تكن قادره على ان تقدم
لمجتمعها ما يصلحها يعني ذلك انها لا تصلح
ابدا وانا ما يعني ذلك ان عليها ان تتطور
ان تاخذ باسباب المعرفه ان تفهم الواقع من
جديد وان تحين خياراتها
[موسيقى]